[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 m de haut sur tv 78 nous
sommes le 31 mai à voici les principaux
titres le mondial de football féminin
s'ouvrira en france dans une semaine
plusieurs équipes vont s'entraîner dans
le département est les tricolores seront
à croissy-sur-seine l'occasion de
revenir sur l'engouement autour de la
discipline exemple à l encours où le
club local prépare sa journée du
football féminin ses organisateurs sont
en plateau
cette édition sera également largement
consacrée aux élections européennes
retour sur les résultats dans le
département et surtout sur les
conséquences pour les formations
politiques
et puis comme chaque semaine l'essentiel
de la semaine à retenir l'actualité des
derniers jours des concours de robots à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aux aides
accordées par le département à la
rénovation des quartiers à
chanteloup-les-vignes le 7 juin débutera
donc la coupe du monde de football
féminin et pour le département des
yvelines c'est croissy sur seine qui
recevra pour ses entraînements l'équipe
de france mais aussi celle des états
unis championne en titre une actualité
qui sera à suivre à bien sûr sur notre
antenne mais une semaine de l'ouverture
de la compétition focus sur un autre
événement la journée du football féminin
dans les yvelines
ce sera et long cours le 1er juin demain
donc dès 9 heures du matin deux invités
mireille l'affront bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue présidente de ce club à vos
côtés et diac connaît bonjour à vous
seul homme
merci d'être venu je me serais senti un
petit peu seul sinon vous êtes le vice
président du club et puis deux joueuses
qui étaient allés long cours et qui
maintenant elles sont à l' aj auxerre
manon couvreur et ophélie gouverne jour
hd2 est bienvenue donc autour de cette
table on va peut-être juste pour
commencer et puisque le mondial féminin
est maintenant dans une semaine vous
demander vos attentes de ce mondial de
football féminin vous attendez de cet
événement qu'il entraînait un engouement
autour de la discipline peut-être pas
tout à fait on espère avoir le
remonté de licenciés que pour le mondial
des garçons de l'année dernière donc
effectivement on essaye à elancourt de
développer cette pratique
1 le foot féminin on a une soixantaine
de licenciés aujourd'hui divisée sur
deux de catégorie 1 les seniors f et le
foot animation
donc oui on a envie vraiment développer
ça le club d'elancourt mais tous les
moyens pour y réussit on a les
structures on a les éducateurs donc oui
on attend plein de choses on ressent
augmente général justement de lors d'une
grande compétition ensuite nous tourner
vers les présidents aussi vivre oui oui
on ressent on sent que ça monte dans le
secteur que tout le monde est excité à
l'idée de regarder nos premiers matchs
si on a reçu les places de la part du
district donc on va pouvoir y aller avec
nos équipes de jeunes et nos seniors et
quelques dirigeants donc on met assez
excitée par par l'événement lui-même
donc oui on a hâte que ça commence et on
tant que joueuse vous attendez du beau
jeu aussi de l'équipe de france vous
pensez qu'elle peut réaliser une belle
performance même si ce sont les états
unis qui sont qui sont championnes en
titre peuvent aller au bout vous suivez
le parcours régulièrement cette équipe
féminine chacune oui vous essayez c'est
pas toujours évident vous rêvez de cette
équipe féminine peut-être un jour
pourquoi pas on va parler de vos
entraînements aussi et et du travail que
vous menez avec avec le club d'auxerre
et l'on court c'est le deuxième si je me
trompe pas plus grands clubs à avoir une
présidente à sa tête c'est bien ça c'est
ça veut dire beaucoup de pression pour
vous de montrer l'exemple vous le prenez
leurs dettes d'être récompensé par la
ligue dernièrement donc c'est vrai que
c'était c'était une surprise mais c'est
aussi oui ça montre le travail qu' à
faire pour des grosses structures comme
les nôtres donc seul on n'y arrive pas
c'est c'est aussi grâce à toute l'équipe
encadrante qui est avec moi mais oui
c'est assez nouveau mais c'est
découvrir le foot ya une dizaine
d'années j'ai découvert le foot
effectivement avec mes enfants barberis
et je pense qu'on y arrive tous comme ça
mais après voilà c'est c'est bien social
c'est l'implication dans la vie du club
c'est les relations avec les gens et
puis avec les joueurs parce que ça c'est
important c'est effectivement la partie
qui est aussi attachante
tous les week-ends de pouvoir partager
tous ces moments sportifs avec eux on
parle du football féminin alors
forcément je vais vous demander ce que
ça change d'avoir une présidente eu en
fait j'allais dire c'est très moteur
parce que très moteur dans plein de
projets toujours plein d'idées toujours
plein dans vie donc on n'a qu'une envie
c'est de suivre et de s'accrocher à la
locomotive est effectivement du coup on
a initié plein d'action plein de pleins
dé plein d'événements plein de choses et
j'allais dire c'est un privilège d'être
d'être menés à la baguette par notre
président fait à la baguette ou même
vous êtes sévère exigeante et l'exigence
exigeant parlons du avant de parler de
cette journée justement vous parliez des
actions samedi ce sera la journée du
football féminin sur sur elancourt on va
y venir mais quels partenariats vous
avez noué avec auxerre et puis ensuite
je vais vous demander vos parcours
respectives respectifs sa partenaire
rien qu'on a mis en place en 2012
et puis qui a été renouvelée cette année
au mois de novembre partenariat qui
avait besoin d'eux
d'un petit coup de boost de revivre un
petit peu et de montrer effectivement
qu'elle encoure c'est bien un
partenariat officiel qui a toute sa
raison d'être mise en place
donc depuis qu'on a signé en novembre on
a fait on est emmené tous nos jeunes on
a envoyé une centaine de jeunes faire un
plateau là-bas découverte et visiter les
installations le centre de formation les
parents puis à voir les explications et
voir effectivement ce que c'est que le
milieu professionnel et comme on y
arrive on a fait donc une détection avec
l' aj auxerre la semaine dernière sur
les installations des longs cours on
essaie de suivre nos filles au maximum
et effectivement dès qu'on a des joueurs
intéressants que ce soit chez nous ou
des clubs environnants sur lequel on
voit en compétition des joueurs
intéressants on remonte les informations
est notre plus grande fierté est
effectivement ça a été l'année dernière
de pouvoir avoir ophélie et et manon qui
sont rentrés donc à la jsk d'auxerrois
etc ont pu faire une belle saison
non c'est cette signature justement quel
était votre vos parcours respectifs et
pas commencé avec vous à quel moment
vous êtes entré à auxerre est ce que
c'était prévu dès le début qu'elle est
ce plan de carrière qui se dessine alors
j'ai fait ma détection en juin suite à
ça on m'a appelé peu de temps après et
je suis arrivé
à auxerre début septembre il vous aviez
pour ambition de devenir joueuse un plus
haut niveau parce que vous avez débuté
des clubs d'elancourt ah oui et puis
depuis le plus jeune âge et comment ça
se passe à auxerre ça se passe super
bien
c'est une ambiance super
franchement tout se passe bien les
entraînements c'est dur mais c'est ça
que l'on cherche donc c'est super je
vois que vous approuvez les
entraînements sont durs et vous votre
parcours à quel moment commence à se
dessiner le départ pour auxerre as tu un
coup pareil que ophélie donc au mois de
juin je partis passer une détection et
deux jours après j'ai eu une réponse si
bien à vendre pour ça s'est rapidement
quoi avec pour ambition aussi de
continuer à évoluer dans le football
féminin est de poursuivre comment vous
le vivez tout les deux ans actuellement
7 cette explosion engouement on le verra
ensuite si ça se confirme pendant le
mondial féminin et puis en fonction du
parcours des bleus aussi mais d'ores et
déjà c'est déjà un succès d'avoir
l'organisation est de permettre de
médiatiser plus la discipline vous le
ressentez même autour de vous lorsque
maintenant vous dites je fais du
football ça paraît normale entre
guillemets ça choque beaucoup moins les
gens que qu'auparavant quoi donc c'est
bien ça a évolué c'est sa pompe quoi
même chose dans votre entourage ça a été
perçu comme ans parce que vous êtes se
lancer dans le football alors ils m'ont
laissé ils m'ont laissé le choix de
faire ce que j'avais envie
au début c'était compliqué parce que
forcément avant c'était les garçons et
le football maintenant au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est devenu c'est devenu
habituel fin
enfin plein de filles font du foot et du
coup bah moi y'a aucun souci avec ça et
la compétition entre vous parce que
entre vous justement vous êtes 2 du club
d'el encore à jouer maintenant auxerre
est une compétition on a les vanités
entre vous les liens vous les suivez
encore ah oui alors on va remercier le
club qui les a libérés pour revenir
juste pour le moment cette édition là et
qui ensuite auxerre et mathieu bideau
qui égalise à être libéré aujourd'hui
pour qu'elles soient avec nous non mais
c'est important qu'elle soit là et elles
ont vécu une belle année aussi l encours
et voilà c'est ça leur tenait à coeur
net sur le plateau avec nos sessions
peut-être de nouvelles ophélie et manon
sur les prochaines années parce que
demain on va s'organiser c'est dur mais
points à sept journées du foot féminin
elle est organisée surtout par le
district c'est la troisième ou quatrième
année qui met ça en place moi c'était
une attente cette année je voulais
absolument effectivement avoir cette
journée en terrain d'accueil parce que
voilà une femme présidente on a des
filles
c'était l'année du mondial donc on avait
envie effectivement de d'être présent
sur cette journée donc ça sera une
grosse manifestation toute la matinée il
va y avoir donc les plateaux ce qu'on
appelle les plateaux fille au foot donc
est tout petit laid tout petit jusqu'au
une 11 ans u11 f excusez moi donc ça se
passera sur le terrain de rugby à
elancourt et sur le terrain de foot sur
les deux terrains synthétiques et leurs
meilleurs atouts tout les u13 f sur
toute la matinée jusqu'à 14h et derrière
on va
on permet toutes les finales
départementales donc voilà c'est ignorer
facettes ucf et seniors féminines partir
de 16h45 avec des équipes d'elancourt
engagé alors heureusement pas oui
équipes engagées sur toutes les petites
la finale on aurait aimé la jouer voilà
on a perdu en demi finale donc c'est nos
clubs voisins de trappes qui sera
finaliste contre carrière qui était
notre opposant en direct au championnat
en tout cas c'est ouvert au public donc
féminin c'est une journée pour venir
voir le le foot féminin est ce que ce
sera une petite mise en jambes avant le
début des choses sérieuses pour les
bleus les tricolores cette fois ci
figureront et si ça donne officiellement
on vous attend sur le mois de juin on a
des portes ouvertes pour justement
accueillir ces jeunes filles tous les
renseignements sur votre site internet
afin que les dates des portes ouvertes
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre ans est
revenu sur ce plateau mais c'était
encore à vous d'être venue d'auxerre
pour évoquer rapidement mais on aura
l'occasion de vous faire revenir vos
parcours respectifs et puis demain cette
journée du football féminin sur elle en
cours merci à vous merci à vous dans un
instant nous allons revenir sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
déjà notre rubrique ça s'est passé comme
chaque vendredi nous vous ouvrons les
portes de nos archives nous retournons
en 2014 la date du précédent scrutin
européen nous votions encore à l'époque
par circonscription
[Musique]
le fn premier parti attrape après ces
élections européennes de peu mais c'est
inscrit dans le marbre le front national
réalise 18 60% des voix
en 2009 le parti frontiste n'avait
obtenu que 4 60% des suffrages un
résultat d'autant plus regardées à la
loupe que c'est dans cette ville
socialiste que siègent notamment en
qualité de conseiller municipal
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
benoît hamon le parti de marine le pen
devance de quelques voix la liste
socialiste et la liste front de gauche
l'ump est le quatrième parti à noter
également que seulement 25% des
électeurs trappistes se sont déplacés
aux urnes
le fn qui arrive en seconde position à
la verrière avec 17 points 16 % des voix
derrière la liste front de gauche
couleur politique du maire sortant le ps
est troisième l'ump 4e en 2009 le front
national n'avait réalisé que 3 49% des
voix
une surprise à magny les hameaux villes
socialistes l'ump arrive en tête avec 16
points 64% des voix talonné par le ps 16
34% par contre pas de surprise à
elancourt où l'ump réalise 25,49 % des
voix le maire de la commune jean michel
fourgous était septième sur la liste
d'alain lamassoure mais le résultat du
parti dans la circonscription de l'île
de france ne lui permet pas d'être élu
seuls quatre députés ump iront à
strasbourg les autres communes de
l'agglomération concerne leur couleur
politique à guyancourt c'est le parti
socialiste qui arrive en tête avec 18
points 40% des voix devant l'ump le fn
et la liste udi modem à montigny le
bretonneux la vie du divers droite
michèle losier l'ump réalise 20 77% des
suffrages devant la liste udf modem
même cas de figure à voisins le
bretonneux la commune avait été emporté
en mars dernier par l'ue dei alexandra
rosetti le parti centriste réalise 21,02
% des suffrages devancé de deux points
par l'ump le front national réalise plus
de 12% des voix là où en 2009 il n'avait
même pas atteint les 2% voisins le
bretonneux qui remporte la palme du
civisme pour l'agglomération plus de 50%
des électeurs inscrits se sont déplacés
aux urnes au tour de saint quentin en
yvelines a noté que l'ump confirme son
ancrage
un bon repas la ville auparavant divers
gauche avait basculé à droite aux
municipales de mars
même cas de figure à bois d'arcy où
l'ump fait plus de 23 % des voix contre
12% pour le ps
dans ces deux villes auparavant à gauche
à noter la forte progression du front
national qui arrive en seconde position
un fn également sur la deuxième marche
aux clayes-sous-bois à saint cyr l'école
et à coignières reléguant le parti
socialiste comme troisième formation
dans ces communes dans les yvelines
globalement l'ump reste majoritaire avec
24 86% des voix s'est toutefois dix
points de moins qu'aux dernières
élections européennes de 2009
le front national le second partie du
département avec 17 77% des suffrages en
2009 à la liste d'hubert dubois n'avait
seulement totalisé 3 95%
c'est donc le grand gagnant de ces
élections du délit modem et troisième et
le parti socialiste 4e avec 11 89% des
voix
une consolation pour la formation de
gauche en 2009 dans les yvelines
harlem désir n'avait seulement réalisé
que 11 60% des voix
un perdant dans le département europe
ecologie les verts
en 2009 la liste menée par daniel cohn
bendit avait totalisé 19 58 % des voix
cinq ans plus tard la liste verte n'en
porte que 7 64% des suffrages
[Musique]
nous passons à l'essentiel de la semaine
après un retour sur les européennes en
les résultats de cette année à présent
2019 dans le département à la liste la
république en marche modem arrive donc
en tête devant europe ecologie les verts
et le rassemblement national 3 yvelinois
deviennent ainsi des députés européens
mathilde andraud m mounir satory et
françois-xavier bellamy et ce week end
mathilde andraud m mounir satouri seront
les invités de nicolas kirilow 8 sur la
cliff lee lovitz pardon sur notre
antenne pour le 7-8 europe
je vous propose d'ores et déjà d'écouter
les réactions des différents
représentants locaux
la sociologie évolue énormément les
citoyens sont beaucoup plus près à
comprendre que le clivage gauche droite
franchement n'a plus aucun sens là où
les partis politiques peut-être anciens
s'accrochent encore à ce clivage gauche
droite qui honnêtement n'a plus aucun
sens si on va le voir avec les
municipales il va vraiment une question
de projet de ville pas du tout de gauche
droite
la sensibilité de nos concitoyens sur la
question de la critique est logique
la sortie des pesticides est présente
dans l'esprit des six ans et puis je
crois que les chinois on en a la foire
art du règne sans partage de la droite
ait l'air et le score en et
démonstrations et que jusqu'à la la
dynamique de la république en marche si
elle a marché pendant les dix le crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de déception
je suis positif c'est le fait qu'au tour
de mantes-la-ville nos scores sont bons
on est en tête
donc je pense qu'en l'occurrence quand
on peut atteindre à pour former voire
nationale à un endroit il fait des
petits je pense que film est ce la
meilleure preuve que nous essayer c'est
l'adopter
pas très honnête sondages donnaient à
trèbes je pensais en fait même que les
sondes amic qui s'était mise en place
autour de la candidature de france
évidemment c'était une surprise de
mauvaises surprises mais plutôt une
surprise pour moi c'est pas dans ces
moments là qu'il faut voilà est fier de
son avenir antichar 30 sa respiration
qui chausse poser un petit peu qu'il
faut beaucoup consulté tout ce qui est
en notre parti maintenant à l'extérieur
du parti ont une voix qui compte pour la
droite républicaine
moi je conserve la condition que
by nécessité ou filer trois fois chemin
d'avoir un parti républicain entre le
rassemblement national est en marche et
l'autre surprise de ces européennes
c'est la participation on l'annoncé
basse elle s'établit finalement à 51%
plus haut que ce qui avait été prévu
dans les yvelines s'est également du
jamais vu depuis 25 ans la participation
pour ces élections européennes atteint l
53,92 % presque huit points de plus par
rapport au scrutin de 2014
dans le reste de l'actualité de cette
semaine les associations musulmanes
réunis au sein à ducarme 78 ont
accueilli des élus des représentants
religieux pour célébrer ensemble la
rupture du jeûne en ce mois de ramadhan
c'était à coignières le reportage de
miquel et demi dont des juifs des
musulmans des chrétiens les communautés
religieuses ont répondu à l'invitation
lancée par le cames 78 le collectif des
associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de ses
environs a organisé son 4e dîner annuel
en plein ramadan
le rendez-vous a débuté par les discours
objectif rencontrer la cohésion entre
les représentants des différents cultes
du territoire il ya toujours besoin de
rappel et pas d'eau rappelle
nécessairement personnes de cette
assemblée la mais peut-être le rappelle
qu'il faut qu'on soit tous vigilants
ensemble face à une ambiance qui n'est
peut-être pas des meilleures un climat
qui peut quelquefois être anxiogène
c'est une opportunité de dialogue et de
fraternité et je crois que au jour le
jour la paix sociale se construit comme
ça par la connaissance réciproque et le
dialogue ensemble je crois que nous
sommes sur la bonne voie pour donner
exemple à la jeunesse du coin
exemple de rapports harmonieux dans la
salle et sur la scène des personnalités
politiques du département des maires de
toute étiquette le président du
département pierre bédier le préfet
jean-jacques brot ou encore des députés
je crois que le fait qu'on soit là en
tant que parlementaire en tant que
représentant de l'état s'est démontré
que la concorde républicaine c'est
d'arriver justement à ce que ensemble
dans une même salle quelles que soient
nos convictions religieuses qu'on aime
qu'on en ait pas on est en capacité
ensemble de faire nation et ça c'est ce
que nous permet dalaï cité et je pense
que être présent c'est finalement porter
notre témoignage à cela la soirée s'est
terminée par une rupture du jeûne du
ramadan entre les 100 invités présents
le rendez vous devrait à nouveau être
organisées l'année prochaine par le
cames 78 c'est aussi cette semaine le 28
mai que le département des yvelines a
confirmé son engagement pour la
politique de la ville avec l'octroi
total de 18 millions d'euros à la
transformation du quartier de la noé à
chanteloup-les-vignes un nouveau
logement maison médicale citée éducatif
pourront ainsi voir le jour à saint
quentin en yvelines nouvelle édition en
début de semaine du ski robe ce concours
qui permet aux plus jeunes de découvrir
de s'essayer à la programmation
informatique est le reportage d'aurélie
explosion de joie pour ces classes de
cm1 et cm2 de l'école de la nouvelle
amsterdam à elancourt ils viennent de
terminer premiers de leur groupe ils se
sont préparés toute l'année pour cette
quatrième édition du challenge robotique
à skis robes ont déjà fait tourner avant
chez owens la lumière du show
on a travaillé dur pour ça pour faire ça
les robes on les a bien calibrée tout
s'est très bien déroulé pendant deux
jours mille élèves de la maternelle à la
seconde se sont affrontés sur la scène
du prix sema et long cours
le principe faire évoluer un petit robot
sur un parcours semé d'obstacles thème
retenu cette année robotique et cinéma
pour récolter un maximum de points il
fallait arriver jusqu'au trophée on
trouve ça intéressant parce que ça nous
faisait travailler dans plusieurs
domaines notamment au niveau des
mathématiques mais aussi au niveau du
français sur la rédaction des textes les
mises en scène aussi filmé et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup dans le repérage dans
l'espace organisé par saint quentin en
yvelines et l'éducation nationale seront
des voix nue elle permet de mettre en
avant l'enseignement du codage à l'école
80% des emplois demain seront liés au
numérique donc il faut vraiment mission
améliorer nos cultures numériques
l'implication plus des enfants
extraordinaires de vous voyez qu'ils
sont heureux ils sont ils prennent du
plaisir à prendre
chaque année on se rend compte qu'on
n'embarque de plus en plus de classes de
plus en plus d'établissements et les
partenaires sont toujours très réactifs
pour nous accompagner sur ce projet
chaque apprenti codeurs a été récompensé
pour son investissement est d'ici 2020
100 % des écoles de saint quentin en
yvelines pourront être équipés d'outils
numériques
[Musique]
chaque semaine avec nos confrères de via
grand paris et diffusée sur la tnt nous
revenons aussi sur l'actualité dans le
reste de l'île de france aujourd'hui
direction l'essonne où la ligne 18 est
loin de faire l'unanimité un collectif
s'élève contre l' étude socio
économiques réalisés par la société du
grand paris
l'impact socio-économique de la ligne 18
est remise en question par un collectif
essonniens
selon le collectif colosse les
hypothèses avancées par la société du
grand paris serait tronquée et parmi des
informations rejetée il y à l'estimation
du nombre de voyageurs qui emprunterait
la ligne 18
ils se rêvent à 1000 par jour en heure
de pointe matinale selon la société du
grand paris
pour le collectif ce chiffre relèverait
de l'utopie
les prévisions de fréquentation sont
extrêmement faibles
elles vont jusqu'à 5000 passagers
alors à l'heure de pointe en 2030 à
l'horizon 2030
et là je ne parle que de la section qui
va jusqu à saclay la section qui va au
delà vers versailles est encore beaucoup
moins fréquenté un gain de temps qui
n'évolue pas faux selon la société du
grand paris qui a établi une étude selon
laquelle pour un trajet
versailles-chantiers aéroport d'orly
le voyageur économiserait 45 minutes de
son temps aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
capacité d'aller sur le plateau de
saclay en dehors d'une ligne de bus qui
est déjà saturé et que nous avons
concernant renforcer mais il n'y a plus
aucune marge de manoeuvre et il suffit
d'aller sur le site de la société du
grand paris pour voir les gains de temps
de parcours qui seront offerts demain
grâce à cette ligne 18 et également la
baisse du trafic automobile parce que
c'est un des objectifs est elle est
rentable
tout simplement parce qu'elle va relier
demain des points extrêmement importante
évidemment le pôle d'orly qu est le
premier pôle sud francilien la ville de
massy qu'une ville importante et qui en
plein développement
tout le secteur du plateau de saclay qui
en train de se développer et puis
ensuite versailles plus à l'ouest qui a
également une très grande ville du sud
francilien l'impact environnemental de
la ligne de métro est lui aussi remise
en question l'année dernière les maires
de magny les hameaux et châteaux forts
ainsi que ceux de saclay et ville et le
bâcle en essonne ont adressé une lettre
ouverte à nicolas hulot
alors ministre de la transition
écologique les élus demandé de trouver
une alternative au métro aérien
ils s'inquiètent de la pollution et des
nuisances sonores qu'une telle
infrastructure peut engendrer le viaduc
de 10 mètres de haut est lui aussi très
critiqué par les opposants au projet la
mise en service de la ligne est prévue
pour 2026 et pour refermer cette hebdo
un bon anniversaire à la radio hervé vs
radio vexin val de seine diffusée sur le
96 2 va fêter dans quelques jours ses 40
ans lancé en 1979 aux mureaux au milieu
de nombreuses radios pirates elle s'est
ensuite ancré dans le paysage des radios
libres son président étaient en plateau
cette semaine avec grégory canal et
c'est une bande de copains et qui ont eu
cette idée donc délocalisé quelquefois
dans la forêt dans des dans des
bâtiments
et puis en 80 donc les radios libres ont
eu le droit de démettre
et bien justement rendu avec ça en a
profité pour créer l'association ac vs
associations que la communication dans
la vallée de la seine et donc radio
vexin val de seine a demandé des
fréquences qu'elle a obtenu c'est une
radio pluriculturelle nous avons des
émissions justement communautaire
émission italienne émission yougoslave
et à des portugais aussi qu'ils ont
leurs émissions donc voilà mais chaque
identité à la parole on passe toute la
culture européenne africaine et c'est ce
qui est justement l'impact l'impact de
notre radio sur la ville des mureaux et
sur d'autres vivent les identitaires se
retrouvent et bien sûr on n'oublie pas
la musique française qui est qu'il a
avec avec aussi du métal si tu fais ça
eut d'ailleurs les killers de nous au
passage parce que c'est une émission qui
est très écouté sur sur notre radio
c'est la fin de cet hebdo prochain point
sur l'actualité en direct ce sera 18
heures à lundi et puis aussi 24 heures
sur 24 sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile
[Musique]
là